Hey!
How are you doing?
Hey, Roger, how are you?
Just relaxing in the Swiss Alps.
Take a look!
Yeah, it's good. Good, good for you.
Listen, about the Switzerland film you want me to do?
Yes!
Did you see the mood film I sent you?
I'm watching it as we speak.
I don't like it.
What?
Just look at where you are, Roger.
I mean, you got your mountains, your skiing resorts,...
...your charming little towns, green valleys...
There's no drama!
No drama at all!
Seriously?
But did you see the bits with the sunset?
Roger, from a certain type of actor, I need an edge, conflict, jeopardy.
Switzerland is just too perfect!
Yeah, I guess you're right.
That's exactly what I am talking about!
You guys are too nice!
Okay, listen.
How about the two of us on this special mission?
We ski down the slope.
What?
We're skiing down a slope together?
We go even skydiving.
Come on...
Then we land on these fields, and the cows are grazing.
Roger, I have to be honest with you.
It's not happening.
Ah!
Sorry, Roger.
Maybe call Hanks.
Who?